[Music]
shia labeouf spent a morning behind bars
he was arrested Saturday in Savannah
Georgia after reportedly getting out of
control and we obtained the police body
camera footage of Shai his arrest
ranting and swearing at police no tops
tel et this all started after Shia
allegedly approached an officer and
asked for a cigarette and quickly became
aggressive and disorderly in the video
recorded around 4:00 a.m. Saturday Shia
calls the arresting officer the same
derogatory term no less than 10 times
during their car ride you can hear the
cops apparent frustration exiting the
squad car once at the jail Shia appears
to go into a tirade about his handcuffs
his cuffs are too tight why am i cuffed
to a female officer seemingly unaware of
the transformer star celeb status tries
in vain to get basic info then this male
officer gets up compliment the 31 year
old now faces charges of obstruction
disorderly conduct and public
drunkenness a rep didn't respond to our
request for comment Shia was released
Saturday on a $3500 bond
[Music]
you